this is the last fractal that I'll be
showing you but there are tons well in
fact I very deliberately restricted the
kinds of factors that I've shown you
based on what can be drawn in fairly
simple terms
now this is about the limit of what
we're going to do nothing there are
other ones out there but even this is
actually kind of too hard to do by hand
we're just gonna do it roughly okay so
when you're going to start and I don't
you don't have equipment there that's
okay just do this properly is for a
large circle see I said okay okay so
you'll have a large circle there okay
now what we're going to do is within
this circle we're going to draw other
circles okay that doesn't sound too
complicated right yeah yeah so this is
pronounced the Apollonian gaskets by the
way tip for you I have actually no idea
whether that's how it's pronounced but
if you never see something were you like
don't inhale let's pronounce just settle
it in your mind and then sound confident
when you say and though
must be absolutely like I have no idea
anyway might say a gasket is a thing
with lots of holes in it okay so we are
going to make holes in this circle and
all the holes will be circular okay so
here's an example now we're all gonna do
slightly different ones but we'll start
off by doing one the same okay now I
think here's what I will do it um the
important thing you need to get is we
going to
drawn a whole bunch of circles every
circle you Joel they must all be what we
call okay I'm content and tangential
okay what's that mean what's that means
it means they share a tangent so for
example ego here's two circles okay and
I can draw a tangent between these
that's tangent to both of them so
another way of saying it is that they
just touch they just touch by the way
that's actually very important helpful
way to say it because the word tangent
would tangent we actually have another
word in English which has to do which
shows you where this word comes from
it's when things just touch what's the
word for things and they just talk to
her you can touch them tangible thing we
say means intangible if you can touch
them right so tangents I think that are
just just touching so I'm going to draw
some circles in here he's where I'm
going to stop I'll do this
there you go
okay so so here's a circle and I want
you roughly draw yours similar to mine
now what we've done is we've created a
big hole you're not going to put any
more circles in here but now you've got
this part around here now what we want
to do is fill that with as many code
tangential circles as we can and then
previous ones main cares okay so for
instance it looks to me like the biggest
diameter I can fit will be over here
right as you go further up against
smaller smaller smaller
okay so let's draw a strong one and now
like I said you actually can do this
properly with a compass and measurements
and all that and it is insanely hard to
do accurately so we're just going to do
it
roughly okay so I'm guessing okay so
there you go there's a circle and I can
keep going around the circumference of
this thing like so the circles will get
smaller
okay you can see what's happening right
are you gonna go all the way around both
ways I'm gonna finish doing this pot in
a second when you'll notice that just
like here I punched a hole in the circle
right and then I left this space around
the edge now let me punch all these
holes I've got more little gaps for
instance he's 1 over here right and I
can fit a big circle in there like so
so like that and then and then I can fit
more in here right okay you getting the
idea I'm gonna fill it in as much as I
can you can see this is a fractal
because of what what quality doesn't
exhibit Reimer it's repetitive it's self
similar rights got scale symmetry like
crazy so all of ours although that's my
drawing right now I'm going to look
quite similar okay but there are tons of
different kinds of Apollonian Gasquet
okay I'll just fill out a bit more of
this and then I'll show you another one
let me show you two quick variations on
the aquilonian gasket okay the first one
is we always start with this circle
right that one's better now my first
initial hole kind of defined everything
once you got this one right everything
else kind of falls out from there but
there's nothing to say you have to do it
like this you can troll for instance
here's another common one you can draw
if you put in the center of the circle
there and then draw two equal circles
like sir I'll try my best
okay so what you're getting at this one
is gonna be quite symmetrical as you can
see so I can do another one yep okay and
you can continue right and you'll get a
completely different gasket because of a
different starting foot okay so number
one you can vary what your initial holes
are okay you could have three
equidistant ones if you like and the
other main way is that you don't have to
start with one big circle for instance
you can start with this guy
okay in some ways this is easier because
you know we can say inscribe a circle
inside that that's the biggest circle
you can fit you know something like this
I guess